la parole est à françois noël buffet
pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ces derniers jours encore été
marquée par les drames de l'immigration
plusieurs morts au large de la grèce des
policiers et singulièrement un crs
blessé ce week-end encore à calais
de semaine en semaine la situation se
dégrade le nombre de migrants ne fait
qu'augmenter à calais et nouvelle jungle
secret aujourd'hui à grande-synthe
on parle de près de dix mille personnes
sur les deux sites
malgré les 125 containers mis en place
pour accueillir 1500 personnes à calais
un camp humanitaire qui sera créé à
grande-synthe de toute évidence les
moyens qui sont mis en oeuvre sont très
insuffisants pour répondre à cette
situation même si vous traitez l'aspect
humanitaire et on ne peut pas vous en
vous faire le reproche
quatre grands problèmes demeurent le
premier c'est que l'ordre républicain
n'est pas assurée les sites ne sont pas
sécurisées le contrôle général des
personnes n'est pas assurée
malgré les niveaux le nouveau moyen mis
en place qui ne semble pas fonctionner
d'ailleurs les migrants refusant de se
faire enregistrer les auteurs
d'infractions ne sont pas poursuivis
devant les tribunaux et ceux en
situation irrégulière perdure sur le
site
une absence de traitement administratif
des situations l'ofpra et nos autres
services n'assure que des missions
temporaires une absence de politique
européenne
quand la france prendre at elle enfin le
leadership pour une mise en place
effective d'une agence européenne de
contrôle des frontières enfin façade
située à 6 à cette situation des accords
du touquet ne semble plus du tout
adaptée avez vous engager des
discussions avec nos amis britanniques
monsieur le ministre l'heure n'est plus
aux annonces il y a urgence
quelles solutions concrètes à la hauteur
des enjeux que je viens de rappeler est
vos capacités de proposer aux français
merci merci pour nous répondre
la parole au secrétaire d'état chargé
des relations avec le parlement devait
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur françois noël buffet je crois
que vous connaissez bien ces questions
et je trouve tout à fait dommageable de
passe souligné le rôle particulier de la
france et en l'occurrence de bernard
cazeneuve
s'agissant de la prise de conscience au
plan européen des impératifs que nous
avons notamment pour mettre le
dispositif frontex à un niveau de
réponse qui correspondent aux enjeux de
la crise migratoire que connaît l'europe
aujourd'hui vous le savez aussi l'état
en liaison d'ailleurs avec les lisent
les élus locaux notamment madame
bouchard qui est une ancienne collègue
qui a quitté récemment le sénat nous
avons multiplié les initiatives pour
apporter des réponses à la situation
migratoire particulière de calais ainsi
l'état a déployé un dispositif policier
en fait sans précédent tout à la fois
pour surveiller la frontière assurer la
sécurité des calaisiens 17 unités de
forces mobiles vous le savez la bac les
polices des frontières sont déployés
dans le calaisis des travaux de
sécurisation très importante et conduit
depuis le début du mois de janvier sur
l'ensemble de la zone
1ce notamment la frontière est
aujourd'hui étanche
on ne passe pas à calais et cela doit
être dit cela doit être reçue il n'y a
plus de passage et donc il n'y a pas
véritablement de possibilités pour ces
migrants de croire qu'ils pourront
passer sans l'accord des pouvoirs
publics
en grande bretagne les milices de
l'intérieur a également donné des
instructions très fermes pour que
l'action énergique engagées contre les
filières d'immigration clandestine se
poursuivre 28 filières ont été mises à
bas filière op envers le royaume uni
1754 étrangers en situation irrégulière
à calais ont été reconduits en 2015
enfin pour répondre à l'urgence
sanitaire vous l'avez
notez le gouvernement a mis en place des
propositions concrètes en plus des
centres d'accueil de jour pour offrir
des prestations élémentaire un centre
d'accueil provisoire 15 cents places et
604 personnes
aujourd'hui ils sont accueillis les
tailles veille à l'adaptation permanente
du dispositif et il se déploie aussi sur
la région de dunkerque de grande synthe
là encore cocoon avant une action très
déterminée de l'état sur ces questions
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à notre collègue yannick
cas au pardon monsieur buffet excusez
moi monsieur le ministre
ils étaient 2000 avant l'été 2015 4000
au mois de septembre
ils sont dix mille aujourd'hui ça veut
bien dire que les moyens mis en oeuvre
sont nettement insuffisants et qu'il
convient vraiment de se doter de
dispositifs pertinent pour pouvoir enfin
résoudre cette situation
merci